now for a short time this week MPs
considered breaking up for their summer
holidays early the plan was eventually
dropped and widely seen as an underhand
attempt by the government to limit the
amount of time for backbenchers to plot
against her resume but fear not
there'll be no slacking or early
holidays on the pledge after all I need
all the time I can get for my campaign
to get Greg kicked off the show coming
up after says immigration was the true
winner in the World Cup
maajid urges caution over design of
babies Greg is on an anti-trump crusade
again and Michelle says hands off my
sausages
but first it's me she's done it
she's only bloom and well gone and done
it showing she boasts the hide of a
rhinoceros the ability of the Steely
Estelle tea shoot outside and the
cunning of the raddest of the love
island love rats Prime Minister Theresa
May seems able to pack the walking boots
for US summer halls surrounded by her
own Conservative MPs many of whom are
revolting in every sense of the word
Mother Teresa
must have enjoyed a holy intervention to
limp over the line but now is the time
Prime Minister to react to your very own
May Day you have presided over and
sanctioned months of pitiful indecision
when you return seize the moment shrug
off the quotes fog of self-doubt and
miserable permanent limbo Boris Johnson
speaks off and extol a vision of a
brexit which makes us all yearn rather
than yawn we pay 650 MPs a minimum of 77
thousand pounds a year is it too much to
ask you prime minister to lead them to
divine a solution to all of this
otherwise what precisely do we pay for
[Music]
it's a very very difficult position
she's eaten shortly I mean whatever she
does she's gonna face opposition and I a
while back I think on this show as well
as elsewhere I've said that ultimately I
think what's gonna happen is that the
heartbreak steers will be dissatisfied
with whatever she proposes and of course
we remain as will be dissatisfied with
whatever she proposes and we'll end up
in this kind of unholy alliance together
opposing her measures which could lead
to a vote whether in Parliament or a
people's vote but I do think ultimately
it's the most unenviable job that anyone
could have in a moment and it could be
the reason why she hasn't been toppled
because no one else wants to be in that
position shortly is a fair point I you
know Greg as I watched Boris Johnson's
resignation speech I remember something
you said on the pledge some weeks ago
but none of the real Brett suitors have
ever sold a vision they've never told us
of where we're going to go and I've been
struck by that by mrs. May and I was
struck again by Boris Johnson we still
haven't had any and that's what I'm
saying get some and indeed it is
reported that she's going on a
nationwide tour but she wants to
reconnect with the good she's got to
sell a vision doesn't she well it's a
very strange thing for me to say but I
have some sympathy with her actually I
came to inclusion this week she has got
a job that you can't do it's not do what
you can't do it it's not doable
therefore there is no there is no
solution she could come up with that is
gonna get for the House of Commons just
news again and therefore where does that
leave us break a second vote well I mean
in the end the choice is going to be I
suspect no breaks it or crash out no
place it will go down well Greg no well
now that we're crashing out let me tell
you and I think that's probably why I
give you in the end you'll have some
sort of second vote because you won't
get either those to the House of Commons
as it sits so either you go to a general
election in which case you'll get Jeremy
Corbyn in the Labor Party I suspect
because you know you see the swing
against the toys this week is enormous
you know all you've got to have another
vote sure well as I say you
Parliament won't be able to decide not a
majority another vote for what you want
to redo the brexit my friend no I think
you say to them look this is where we've
got to we can't decide you decide you
can even have another vote on either
crashing out or we remain in shall we
look you've mentioned Boris Johnson just
speak sure we have a quick look at some
of the things that he's read important
ways this is by no orb Rhino or brexit
in name only but let us again aim
explicitly for that glorious vision of
Lancaster hunts a strong independent
self-governing Britain that is genuinely
open to the world not the miserable
permanent limbo of checkers it is not
too late to save bretzel see you've
mentioned as well as swing away from the
Tories and when you look at where a lot
of that swing is going to it's going
towards you Kip which to me reinforces
the fact that most breakfast here
certainly every brick city that I've
ever spoken to doesn't regret their
votes they've not sat here now and gone
oh if only I could rewind time back to
two years I would have voted differently
I actually think people's resolve has
gotten stronger in favourable exit polls
show that well I don't think the polls
show well let's get you in on this there
was a fantastic piece written by former
speechwriter for David Cameron Claire
photos in one of the papers in which she
talked about and and I actually agree
this it doesn't matter whether you
supported Tony Blair but he puts
elevation whether you supported Margaret
Thatcher she could David Cameron you
know where I'm going I don't actually
agree with what Boris Johnson is I don't
think there's ever been a vision
Lancaster gate or anywhere else from Mrs
May as regards this what do you say I
think I mean I agree I think we are I've
said this so many times the show we are
lacking leadership we're lacking
leadership that's credible that people
can really get behind
that's why Corbin did well but on this
he's also weak and I think you know the
only person who seems to have a vision
at the moment and I hate to say it is
Jacob Riis morg and that's why he is
essentially running the show he is
running the show and this is not
representative
my third focuses or of parliament there
is a small hard core group of
to hardliners who hijacked this process
and I also feel sorry for trees may
she's she's being held hostage by them I
don't personally think she's managed it
brilliantly but it is a difficult
situation but I think we all need to
take a step back and rationally appraise
the situation the vision of Jacob Riis
MOG is not a vision we all need to or
have agreed to sign up to and I think
that's clearly evident in the house
homes look at the body language of MPs
when Boris Johnson was speaking he
surrounded himself by this hardcore
group of bricks to use but the majority
of the house have lost any credibility
that he once had has been shot and they
are equally disillusioned by was
happening I just want to quickly show
you when that vote was won this week the
reaction of MPs because everything is on
a knife edge right now the eyes to the
right 305 the nose to the left
302
the atmosphere is so unpredictable and
tense and nobody knows which way
anything is going and that is not a way
to run policy but it's certainly not a
way to conduct negotiations we cannot
achieve anything just come to you in a
minute
but good point F will make so about
resmoke has got a vision I doubt that
you buy into it but that's probably why
it's getting so much education worth
noting by the way - Lib Dem leader and
formerly of damli - miss that that was
yes but yes on the issue of Jacob Riis
mug and and vision of course Anna Subaru
has yet release has been opposing Rhys
Morgan has her own vision listen to what
she had seen now take the origins
incident I knew Margaret Thatcher I work
for Margaret Thatcher my honorable
friend at eight know Margaret Thatcher
I don't pretend to be able to walk in
market Thatcher's booth nobody voted to
be poorer and nobody voted leave on the
basis that somebody with a gold-plated
pension and inherited wealth will
[Applause]
so I just want to say it this they don't
need an opposition do you I think I
think we've got to a stage where and
it's also in response to what you were
saying which I think we've got to a
stage where it doesn't matter how
passionately we feel about remain or
brexit it actually is right now down to
what the practical way forward is and
actually practically I don't see any way
forward because you can be what you or
anyone can be so passionate for wanting
brexit and you've got of course you've
got some Romaniacs out there as well who
almost like militant in there but it
doesn't it doesn't mean anything because
it won't whatever we propose will not
get so it's a No Deal well so it's what
greatest lot great said yeah it's gonna
either be no deal or we stay in and it's
gonna have to either be a vote in
parliament or vote vote by the people
it's the only practical way for but I
think there's a huge appetite now and I
know you will all disagree with me
probably but there is an appetite now
for almost like a trump style
negotiation more that's no deal
but more yeah but that's what I'm saying
and I think they'll say fine we'll have
no deal yeah what would trump achieves
though what does that what does that
achieve in a negotiation is delicately
important I think that you can't go into
negotiation if you're not truly willing
to walk away I think what what how you
know I mean you've done business deals
and negotiations your whole life how can
you go into a negotiation if you're
truly not able to say you know what we
need to list negotiation you haven't got
anywhere to go
you've only got no deal that's your only
negotiate last week when we discuss this
so many opportunities and ideal would be
terrible I think the danger is too great
but I'd be interested in what Nick
thinks because last what you say you
thought no deal will be a disaster than
you you're someone who votes you know
someone who voted out would you change
your vote if it was in no choice no I'm
still I was a reluctant brexit ear yeah
and I'm still a reluctant brexit ear and
if it is no deal so be a no deal and I
think we just got a between negotiations
the difference in me but this and a
business negotiation is that the stakes
in this are the economic prosperity of
the nation you know you can't just walk
away from something that could mean jobs
the currency in
a main mainstay of the economy it's just
not something you can just kind of throw
up in the air but I believe there was
always going to be the risk of a short
term medium term effect of their don't
stand by that but I don't believe that
long term so you talk about currency
crashing yes I course there is a strong
possibility that that would happen but I
think that would be a short-term
situation that would resolve itself and
of course there Boris Johnson is for me
the only person that's ever had any
consistent positivity in terms in terms
of having faith in ourselves and what we
could create and what that would look at
the last moment which way boys why is
having fear from the positivity in your
country no one do you have positive you
was like me you was there on the fence
and then you swung quickly he was very
yeah but do you have fear that actually
everything could be okay in the long
term it's going to be far more difficult
than I think it was but I do think
Britain will probably put itself through
yes